più vado a mettere questo però regate
degli altri però allora qualche giorno
fa qui e non mi ha detto va bene c'è
qualke bella idea per un bel video puoi
sempre parlato il mio canale quel giorno
è arrivato lui luis ha mangiato la
foglia abboccato all'amo
e adesso attraverso la giusta
esposizione mediatica su un canale da un
milione di iscritti
faremo capitolare guglielmo grazie per
esserti fidato di noi o gabriele grazie
a te per girare il video da willy elmo
dai sei troppo buono non dico sul serio
gabriele su una scala da 1 a 10
ti meriti 11 avrò bisogno d'aiuto
svegliati bambino mio abbiamo una
missione da compiere
allora che cosa stiamo facendo qualche
giorno fa ho fatto ordinare 300
arrosticini e gianluigi e adesso stiamo
andando a casa di guglielmo per il
compleanno di arrivino stiamo andando a
prendere gianluigi lo stiamo andando a
prendere soltanto perché c'è la ciccia
dall'aci chiaro è che mangeremo nel
terrazzino di guglielmo a sua insaputa
sai k dico io facciamo tanti auguri
perché il nostro piano funzioni abbiamo
bisogno dello strumento madre questa
bellezza e la nostra macchina con so se
vi ricordate ma in quarantena ci hanno
rotto il vetro per rubare che cosa
normale in possono ruba guardamacchine
non hanno rubato questi ladri di cattivo
gusto la cosa più importante il diamante
allo stato grezzo che abbiamo sempre
tenuto dentro questa mano
no no no no non andate via non vi fate
ingannare dall acqua e poco musone
quello che si vede a quello che ci
cucini sosta non è una comune fornacella
e voglio dargli la giusta esposizione
[Musica]
mazzoni
portaci marano ticino curdo deciso che
se porti mediaticamente proprio occhio
da rosti cini 5k di carbonella e poi
questa è una fornace della prima di
supporto è una forma tale successo da
supporto
ma ragazzi questa mattina ma come l'ha
ospitata e la gente quindi un cerchione
qui sembra una macchina rubata ragazza
io ho paura
il joker ostini a disposizione di osama
la maglietta proposta mediaticamente
lui e non si apre
capita comuni come cazzo vuoi
schiaffeggiare non parla e rituale
nostri schiaffeggia non si mano 300
arrosticini di pecora contro di noi
contro tutti no credito cento ha fatto
in maniera sentito torneo ho capito
questo qui pranzo tv4 avevamo fame
ovviamente vince chi ne mangia di più ma
certo capito i temi degli stecchini
esposizioni quindi esposizione mediatica
di sifilide guglielmo sono finite cavolo
subita da pochi euro
kikkio i tagli al razzo è il mio
compleanno e ci ho più il vino auguri ma
io non lo so non sapevo non avevo idea
che stesse imam e tre centrali una
posizione mediana esposizione media
posiziona miliardi adesso vi insegnerò
ad accendere il fuoco nella maniera
migliore con anzitutto mi carne dello
scoppio non ci ascolta non c'ho scott ex
o dei bicchieri però per il vino prendi
la carige
serviva un successo dopo il caso delle
risposte
voglio di riso non c'è si finisce in
questo finale
io ho pulito tutto a casa mamma ti
ammazzo che infiltra cento del guasto
che vediamo 300 studenti nei pick up
gratuiti servivi il terzino ci servivano
spazi conforme alla legislazione del
momento quindi non ti ho fatto una
palletta di kart arioli questo da una
sorta di fiamma eterna caravano un cad
iodio c'è una roba romane ragazzi le
vostre scarpe di alle scarpe subito no
perché oggi ha capito che ci sarà per
terra olio grasso in un voglio che mi
camminata interrogava cioè per caso
altri 30 di queste cose di selvaggi
state pedini che cambia scusa s sedevamo
le scarpe comunque sia così basta
accendere un pezzettino le braccia i
garanti monio qua adesso c'è solo
bisogno
guardate che rispettando mamma mi ha
guardato e guardano molto smarrisci
perché abbiamo fame mangia murate eccolo
qua si sta giocando da solo si è preso
il bicchiere per seno marini nino pane
si dia inizio alle danze carsi queste
sono le ciabatte per entrare in casa dio
entra con le scarpe ognuno deve mettere
gli stuzzicadenti in un punto a passo la
bandana
nella sfida ognuno deve mettersi cadenti
non un punto dai miei stuzzicadenti
saranno conficcati nel cactus e
guglielmo dei piatti sta scherzando le
ciabatte dentro casa per un fallo a casa
la moda perché mi deve essere sfuggito
qualcosa ci serve un bel brodino e
preparare lo stomaco in mancanza del
brodino la cole non ti fa percepire
grazie tea marco guarda che schifo per
terra che schifo carbonia
più carbone cammino guardassimo così a
doverlo sembra fatto che gli altri per
aver fatto soltanto per volta ci sono
delle piante sono è netta no non si può
quasi non si può come se un po troppo
inserisci quello alleggeriti bello da
qui attacchiamo sono sentiti e rotti di
carne ai 40 e 42 arrosticini e un chilo
ma voi per la cottura mamma beer e
marron non so se hai visto che io ho
preso un mucchio a caso e o
perfettamente coperto tutta la
fornacella sembra un abruzzese doc
motore buonissimo arabi sia con l'acqua
paradiso
ora ti spiego che cos'è l'esposizione
mediatica esposizione mediatica ai un
dovere ma sbaglio fa citando mai mi
affascina
sembra un codice pescosi non metto il
sale queste se mettesse il sale che
stavi buttando dall'alcol
siamo tra di noi devo mettere sale a
mano bottiglie da aspetta perché so così
perché non mi interessa la
responsabilità verso le parti
radicamento alzare l'esposizione
mediatica disposizione macchiati e
quindi anche portacomaro e col tacco
l'avete guardava da schifo
taha esposizione media di casale in
esposizione mi piace allora che schifo
che schifo la maglia insalate al mese e
già fatti da una bottiglia di grappa
mangiarlo visibilmente più ubriaco e c'è
ubriaco la prima andata di arrosticini
pro la propongo il primo arrosticino chi
ha mangiato dalle vestigia tino propongo
anch'io dai sì
avete reso una torta per comprare una
casetta no no per fortuna ci ho pensato
e ho preso vari candeline di lenticchia
mostra la rossignol era invecchiamo
piante migliore io potrei fare in un
colore è primariamente chiamano spende
il candelotto mi vuoi farlo saranno
stici non dico tanti auguri 610 che lo
screzio nè casera e cosenza con da zero
ma adesso lo zero era mai detto che ti
metterò 068 dell'infinito in salita per
sempre
29 posto è il massimo e rigirato il
contrario per essere 6
tanti auguri bellissimo ma avete preso
un 9 in italia sono in vantaggio buona
una si dia inizio alle danze promosso
così lo sapete tutti è stato composto da
questa maglia motto è tecnica nord e al
centro
guarda la tecnica seppellì invece alla
cassa da parte l'idea ragazzo e che
cos'è il sale per terra ditelo subito
aveva con questi segreti e ata garantirà
la prodotte umane
adesso dovrete tutti mangiare per
ossicino in verticale
per mantenere sotto a verticale è caduto
un pezzo 91 concerviano solleva 17 meno
signori ha perso la voglia di vivere
bella sfida da confermati d'ansia
guglielmo sul posto agostino nella
gengiva mamma mia come detto cha la
tassa che a passeggiate riprendo il
mancio tutti questi web ci nascondiamo
dietro un arrosticino diamo spaccandosi
300 arrosticini in quattro in contanti è
vorrei dare la giusta esposizione
mediatica questi due che altrimenti non
avrebbero mai avute nella loro vita
esposizione mediatica o 5.000 frecce al
mio arco ragazzi allora c'è un momento
di stallo possiamo dire di fatica
perassi costavano all'abruzzese e ti
fanno le case nello verrà mangiato una
situazione questa fuggendo hai superato
il filo non legge mai superato chi non
ha superato il chilo e benvenuto nel
club rosso abbondantemente sopra kg non
tanto che io ho utilizzato una tecnica
di mangiare molto rapidamente di modo da
non sentire la sazietà la classica
tecnica della
a vuoto da 1 kg diamo certo non dei miei
perché io vieni discendente del
palarossini fondamento complimenti a
ragazze l'ente cosa che cosa è questo
cosa e arrosticini quale la protegge il
mio arrosticino nella forza non ci credo
non ci credo affatto un po di scena per
farli rilassare un motore a non sembrare
temibile e io facendo la scena
dell'ubriaco faccio credere di non
essere temibile l altro ha mangiato che
arrossisce di tutti ho bisogno di
sgrassare un pò l'ideale per una coca
cola una sgrassi na per eccellenza
eccola la sgrassi na il momento di fare
sul serio i bambini hallyday pochina
fresca d'armi tutti gli arrosticini che
sono rimasti da me di tutto il campione
bisogna mettere tornerà ragazzi ma la
cuocere in cottura a chi seduta fa mi
hai abbandonato per caso lillina se non
è più bello in esposizione mediatica
ancora no guarda me se non ci fosse
l'esposizione mediatica casi d'azione
[Risate]
ben è incominciata
arrivano di stomaco e ancora perché non
lo sapremo mai chi lo sto coso seppur
chievo io sono sempre provato a mettere
questi sulla brace pronto guarda qui ero
abbonato proprio io so altro io alleno
di stomaco ne posso ma gli altri a
livello di salivazione sento che la
bocca non segue il mio stomaco e ancora
in esposizione mediatica molto purtroppo
la prego professore un'altra solo
concerti bella roba altri due dimettono
un'occhiata a questi sei tuoi
ormai stiamo parlando di kit antichi
lista e non sono fatti una metto arte
sul fuoco l forse non è che mi pento
cimitero io personalmente ho superato il
filo abbondantemente ma come mai ad
altri se tu li metti ci costringe a
mangiarla non posso perderla questa
challenge gara io mi sto vergognando dio
secondo me so sotto il basso qi di
gabriele perché lui è andato veloce lo
conosco è uno che lo scatto ok ma la
cosa scioccante quella lì ci stanno
ancora questi cinque pure i vagoni di
giovani arrosticino immagini e tu lo
sono io me ne vado mi arrendo enrico
continua a salari
sei l'orgoglio dell'abruzzo tu devi dire
solo sazio non solo di salivazione ma
questa si consumano mangiare prodotti
del paniere per chi sei scappa ma il mio
problema adesso è la salivazione non è
una questione di stomaco è più difficile
se non ci assaliva digerire un passo dal
27 rimasti kg
non c'è più pronunciato guglielmo mollo
io ho mollato con una falsa andrebbero
molto meglio perché cambi il sapore e la
privazione aumenta quindi buona salsa
barbecue guglielmo dove sono le salse
non esiste che gli dona barbecue ago
che cosa porta alla nutella sto pensando
pensa che bello tipo uscito una per la
prima volta e fare una cosa che tela
bruci per sempre le di panama e
centomila gira verso di tanti stai così
si conferma la prima volta in scena io a
chiedere scusa minuto bassa questo è
l'ultimo sensazione mangiare
bene a questo punto dopo esservi
appropriato indebitamente del canale
conteggi remo finalmente chi ha vinto la
challenge degli arrosticini partendo dal
più scarso di elmo rendite rossi circolo
prende i suoi guglielmo quanti
arrosticini e mangiato 27 poco più di
mezzo chilo di carne
sì mi sento pieno gianluigi mi sono
superato il numero di queste bacchette
ammonta a 70 piazza 70 quasi due chili
chi le 7 di pecora io ho mangiato la
bellezza di sessantuno arrosticini non
mi posso lamentare ma ottimo anzi 62 non
vogliono più panni di apple
infine per l'eagle i diesel del gruppo
quello che ha mangiato più lentamente ma
per più tempo e non mangiate 66
quindi il vincitore corone d'oro per un
attimo voglio ricordare a questo punto
magari mi sono sbagliato la giuria si
accerta ecco questo mi fa capire che sto
cominciando a girare senza il conteggio
era sbagliato per l'igiene e mangiati 60
66 67 e per uno vincere
e gianluigi ne ha mangiato uno pensando
di dover arrivare a 70 quindi era in un
pareggio con enrico se non avesse
mangiato l'ultimo quindi a ledere
rimasto questo andiamo in pareggio ma
c'è la legge non è terra bella un rapper
di gente che di fatto il vostro loro
tanti auguri e mi potrei benissimo
mangiare quella rustici nadar in
pareggio ma è giusto che ci sia un
vincitore in questa challenge che non va
bene per chiudere prima del dolce che
c'è sempre spazio per le stragi e del
dolce perché lo sorprese enrico se
questo video vi è piaciuto e volete
un'altra puntata di appropriazione
indebita del canale di wight commentate
tutti con esposizione mediatica perché
tutti ci meritiamo un po di esposizione
mediatica
alla prossima almeno tre o a 0 3 ore
almeno tre ore mamma mia che depressione
che depressione che ho ma c'è pure dolce
tanti auguri a te
[Musica]
è